[Musik]
er wusste dass bei den offenen stinken
den bundesländern den verkehrskosten na
und wir wissen wie der onkel to print
auf seinen 500 millionen pfund nein na
gut da wirklich ihr euch also folgendes
problem
ich komme viel zu wenig ausländer auf
unsere wunderschöne kaputte autobahn
schön egoistisch von diesem timing
vorschläge zum glücklichsten dobrindt
dem genialen coating eine ganz neue
methode ein pfeil stehen wir uns mal vor
es kommt ein ausländer über die grenze
nehmen mal den worst case an ein türke
brumm brumm
natürlich in einem tiefer blicken 3er
bmw der ist nach deutschland reinke
zählt also als ein ausländer
und jetzt der trick wenn er wieder raus
fährt dann zählen wir immer dabei
so hat das verkehrsministerium wirklich
gezählt und schwupps haben wir als einem
ausländer zum ausländer gemacht so
schwer sich echt nur die türken und der
zahlt doch trotzdem nur einmal ja klar
aber wir zählen ihn zweimal damit unsere
rechnung stimmt nun bist du doch der
oliver krechel glatt auf der blöden
schule in nordrhein westfalen ja stimmt
sogar
aber wenn die maus wenn die maut kaum
geld bringt wozu dann der ganze aufwand
und die beantworte ich dir nach einer
kurzen pause
[Musik]
und wie ist die antwort
ich hoffe du hättest inzwischen die
frage vergessen
jamann wir machen die dort weiter gesagt
haben
das war die machen feierabend man kann
doch nicht alles sein lassen bloß total
schwachsinnig ist wo kann man denn da in
österreich und die niederlande verklagen
uns und am ende blech der steuerzahler
ja ja ich habe jetzt keine zeit ich muss
weiter ausländer sehen keba formal in
graz zwei ausländer ausländer 27
312 5900
das ist mir zu blöd matthias matschke
vielen dank